I think Allyson touched on a lot of
points as to why it would be beneficial
for graduate students and people on
certain career trajectories to think
about science outreach and education and
science communication but I also want to
point out that doing this as an
institution is not charity there is an
amazing return on investment if an
institution were to invest in science
outreach and I'm living breathing proof
of that
so when I think about my story I really
want to tell it in a way that's useful
and so I was really just an and I were
walking down the street to the story
Collider last night and I was sort of
throwing all of my ideas at her and she
sort of helped me find clarity and a
single word to describe what I think
really describes my experience in
science outreach and that's reciprocity
so here's how my story started so I was
a postdoc here I spent a lot of time in
the lab and I also spent a lot of time
doing sicom stuff doing outreach stuff I
volunteered for the bio bus Lou and I
and another couple of colleagues we
would do this discussion series called
spot on NYC it was science on lawn and
whisky and then they were like oh you
can't use that word so we went to spot
on NYC and we were just engaging with
communities in ways that brought people
together on this campus in really unique
and creative ways and one of the
beauties of Rockefeller is that they
kind of like let you do what you want to
do as long as you're not interfering
with anybody else's dream of doing what
they want to do so it's pretty great and
so I knew I wanted to continue my career
inside common outreach because those
experiences were really transformative
for me and I also knew I wanted to stay
at Rockefeller so I made a hail-mary
pitch to mark tes a Levine who was the
then president and I laid out all of
these initiatives around science science
communication and outreach and I said
and I would like to be the person that
does this
wink wink right and he was like oh
sounds good we have an open position
right now for
science outreach program you should
apply for it I was like oh my god what
timing it was amazing
so I within like three days I was now
the director of science outreach at
Rockefeller I was like oh my god what do
I do with this um so but I wasn't the
first person so we actually had an
outreach program it was started in 1992
by this awesome lady
Bonnie Kaiser many of the West Coasters
me know her right so and she ran
something called a summer science
research program for high school
students this is why we are where we
take a small portion of high school
students that are top of their class and
bring them in for seven weeks and they
do some sort of research with one of the
labs here all over Rockefeller and I
thought that was a really great start
but I knew that those kids that were
already science interested they were
already being coached by parents that
were really invested in their time and
invested in their futures where maybe
not the kids that could really use the
science outreach I knew that from my own
experience how hard it was for me to
sort of break out of my culture in my
sort of home life where my parents are
you know I'm a product of a teenage
pregnancy my parents you know they have
a salary job or an hourly job and you
know they're like why don't you just go
to work this is what you do you graduate
college you go to work right they didn't
understand this whole thing so I knew
the uphill battle and so I wanted to
help more kids like that and so I knew
the first thing I had to do was beg for
space so I went to the person who's in
charge of space here at Rockefeller and
every day I went to his office for six
months and I said I would like some
space now and he's like okay I'll think
about it I would like to some space now
okay I'll think about it and finally he
was like fine okay so first lesson is be
super annoying this squeaky squeaky
wheels get the oil right but what I
haven't mentioned yet is the vision of
the development office okay so the
development office for me was absolutely
key there's a woman who runs the
development office her name is Marni
Inhofe she is basically she doesn't know
this but like I bow to her she is my
mentor
she is the smartest person I've ever met
in my life and she sees the potential
that no one else sees and with her
support it really give gave me a path to
building Rakhi to you and so once I got
this space Marni sees this potential and
then allows her team to start helping me
in coaching me better understand the
institutional infrastructure I came in
as a scientist I had the backing of the
science community already I got I know
the lingo I've been in meetings you know
I sort of have that support but what I
didn't understand is how to integrate a
program into the infrastructure and the
Development Office provided me that
clarity they have been mentoring me for
many many years and without them I
wouldn't be here
and so Marni helped me get a my first
bit of funding from a foundation and
with that I was able to hire a full-time
administrator and another scientist to
help run a program called lab
experiences she even coined this thing
called lab initiative learning at the
bench and I like she's a genius I just
love her so we have this thing called
lab initiative and it allowed me to
start building up some hands-on
programming to recruit people from the
communities that I really wanted to
serve and so so I started working with
teachers and I started asking them to
bring their kids into the lab and doing
some stuff and while and we did what we
knew right and as the teachers would
come in we would host these classrooms
of students we would stop the teachers
and say tell us what we did wrong tell
us how we can do better what do you
actually need and over the course of
time we started building up this program
and iterating failing and iterating and
failing and iterating until we're sort
of getting it right now I think I owed
Ellis gets hurt much more right than I
do she runs the lab experiences so she
so Marni sees this and we are deciding
that you know what this is a really
successful situation let's do more right
so we started thinking about ways that
we can synergize and we know that
science out
which is something that donors really
can connect with right so I started
doing these things with the development
office where I would attend some of
these really high-end development events
and talk to the people there and sort of
get them interested in the way we are
approaching science outreach at
Rockefeller and that allowed them to
sort of have a better insight into how
they or if they might want to add
support to the science here right and so
we started doing this thing called
science Saturday which is a festival for
families around the the New York area
you know it's just a one-day thing but
it's a really big endeavor and it allows
us to recruit new donors to the campus
they see the campus they see the
scientists we have about 35 to 40
different science stations run by actual
scientists and by the way what happened
with science Saturday is that it created
a sense of community on this campus that
was never really fully realized prior so
people are coming out of like the labs
the woodwork of the labs to do this
thing and they're saying to themselves
I've never interacted with my colleagues
the way I interact with them you know
what I interact with them in a lecture
setting it's really you know this very
dry situation but what I'm doing this as
part of science outreach what I'm doing
feels so fulfilling it feels so great I
feel so inspired and I feel so energized
and it creates this happiness which i
think is really important so the
reciprocity is there for the scientists
in giving them that that happiness that
they might be craving even though
they're like killing it on nature papers
and science papers and faculty positions
this place is intense with science but
there's still that sort of emptiness and
science outreach really helps them to
fulfill it and so so we started really
building out more and more and more so
working with a development team we're
you know we're using science outreach to
bring in donors we're using science
outreach to Train graduate students on
how to teach how to mentor how do we
have this whole thing on mentoring we we
train graduate students on Scott science
communication skills we're helping them
get jobs right so this is the rest
prosody they come and they volunteer and
they do stuff for us and then we in turn
help them along their career
trajectories we are helping faculty we
they now see the value that we can give
them in terms of you know how they can
approach their science we are allowing
them to write really rigorous broader
impact statements we are allowing them
to contribute to other types of
community engagement and outreach where
they're actually fulfilling something
not just doing it out of the goodness of
their hearts but they're meeting some
criteria that they had to meet that they
didn't necessarily have a mechanism for
I also want to point out that the
reciprocity doesn't just stop with you
know working with development it doesn't
just stop with graduate students
postdocs and faculty it also the
reciprocity is also really important
here with our support staff I don't know
if you've noticed me like high-fiving
our custodians I don't know if you've
noticed me hugging you know the people
doing our catering it's because they see
also science outreach as a mechanism for
their families to be involved and I am
always inviting them to participate and
supporting the students or their
children or their families in some way
and because of that and because we are
an organization that sort of operates
with a really small budget and kind of
under the radar of a lot of things I
need a lot of favors to make this stuff
what it is right and so when I do these
things for the custodial staff or the
catering staff or the teams that are
working behind the scenes and I'm like
oh my god I need like XYZ setup like
tomorrow I'm sorry you know they're like
we got you right and that helps us run
really smoothly too so I think it's
really important to recognize that and
so lastly one of the other arrow eyes
that I think the institution has
experienced through the work that we're
doing in science outreach is this sort
of community relationship with with the
New York City like government and and
policy positions so I don't know if
you've noticed but we have this new
building being built which is like
a segment of 19 Jayant things that got
sort of it's like a sky sky cat when tea
floor skyscraper but instead of being
like this it's like on top of the FDR it
was actually really incredible they like
lifted it from a barge in nineteen cents
and like dropped it on top of the FDR
and these like little lego segments but
in order to get the permit for that that
is a capital improvement for this
university in order to get the permit
for that they had to prove to the New
York City offices that they did
community engagement and that they were
serving the community and guess who
provided the numbers for them me right
and so this is a really important aspect
that we're not necessarily always
talking about we always want to frame
science outreach as what how we can help
the community how we can help graduate
students how we can help postdocs we're
never really thinking about it at least
in my conversations with others we're
not always thinking about it in terms of
like how can we leverage this to help
the university or the institution that
you're working in right and so I just
wanted to point out that the ROI is for
the university are many and can be
leveraged in really smart ways and I
think we need to add these to the
conversations I'm gonna just end in one
second and say that my amazing
colleagues from the development office
are here so Ainsley Emma Pam and Lisa
right here in the front row they're
gonna hang out ya know they're these
people are amazing they've taught me if
you think that this event went smoothly
it's because they taught me how to do it
you know they're amazing and they're
hanging out for this morning so if
anybody wants wants to talk about how to
leverage development or how to think
about development in your context
they're gonna be hanging out ready to
brain dump on you if that is something
that you want to talk about so I'm gonna
leave it at that I'll grant how are we
with time great so if anybody wants to
hand over some questions I'm happy to
take them okay Dagny
so I just wanted to say Jeannie thanks
for those remarks you you really made a
lot of sense and I also would like to
offer the services of the communications
and public affairs offices of your
institutions I don't know how the
universities work but I met an
independent research institution and run
the communications function we are
looking for content we are looking for
scientists who want to share their
stories and to the point of it's not
just about oral communication being able
to stand up in front of an audience
there are so many ways and so many
products that we're thinking about now
especially in this digital world that
allow scientists to communicate and
using the communications office can help
train can help provide opportunities so
please reach out to your communications
folks - I was gonna ask how have you
leveraged leadership of the institution
to talk about outreaches in an important
component of what the university does so
I'm just in full transparency I'm still
really working on that but I don't know
if you saw but my boss gave the opening
remarks yesterday and guess what I
didn't ask him he was like I would like
to give her opening remarks is that okay
and then I went and I cried you know I
was like no no it's you know I guess I
guess it's fine sure
so but we're getting there and another
thing that I learned is that scientists
are really competitive right so I also
leverage that and with science Saturday
the Sun that lab heads are now coming
out and they're like I want to because
we offer rooms and we offer stations and
everybody's like I want a room no I want
a room what is what is a Lieberman load
doing because I want to know you know
and or you know Paulie and I she's like
who's doing what what is Jarvis doing
because we need to we need to make sure
we top that right and so so there
there's a so I almost feel like nervous
about what's gonna happen in the future
there it's been a slow oh there was one
thing that I wanted to you bring up
point up so I'm going to quote person
Anna Maria Sheila I'm kind of gonna
reveal my politics because I was
listening to pod save America and she
was on there and she said for her
activism that how we really come
together as a community is building
people one at a time and for me I think
that's how has been successful here at
Rockefeller we've been built I've been
building people one at a time
I've been talking having coffee with
everybody I could have coffee with you
know figuring out ways we can synergize
and it's been a long haul I've been
doing this for six years and we're
finally on the radar of people and I
think it's important to recognize that
it will not happen overnight
it takes a lot of investment in the
people power hey Sarah kobilka from the
University of Arizona stem Learning
Center and I really liked your idea
about the custodians and talking about
bringing their families to your Saturday
events and when I talked about backwards
design and who's at the table at the
beginning maybe that's a way to get your
audience and maybe you don't have a
custodian sitting at your planning
meeting but what a great opportunity to
bounce ideas off of somebody
to see what that desired audience how
they might respond do you ever do that
so have them sit at the table and help
me plan the events yeah so I mean
sometimes so one of the things that I'm
really trying to work on is bringing
some out reso one of the major languages
spoken here is Spanish and I'm really
trying to figure out how can we do a
spanish-speaking outreach I'm not fluent
I can understand when Edwin was like
clap once I like okay I know that one
right you know but I will not answer
anybody and you know so it's it's it's
and I think Kyle sort of mentioned that
just because you know though you you
know somebody is fluent in a language
doesn't mean that you understand the
culture right and so I will also just
want to acknowledge that they're not
necessarily at the table in the planning
but I do talk to them about like what
are the challenges that your student is
facing like tell me about William does
he like science what does he like and
then I might do something like oh I know
William likes to build things so I have
this little kit in my lab that I'm like
you know what it doesn't matter if it's
missing here give this to William you
know and so those small things is what I
do but I'm not necessarily saying come
here and let's brainstorm about how I
should plan an outreach event but maybe
this is something I should do okay one
maybe quick hold on Lisa wants to say
something hi my name is Lisa crest Bock
and I'm in the Development Office and we
want to thank Jeannie for the nice shout
out but I have to tell you obviously if
you've seen her in action for us it's a
major mutual appreciation society
between science outreach the whole
science outreach staff and the
development office and it's an absolute
pleasure working together but I think
one of the things I just like to point
out when you were talking about the
president coming and other people
getting involved one of the great things
in terms of our office and other people
being involved is that the engagement
and the communication really happens and
I think often you're when one's focused
in education it's on how to communicate
to your students and how to communicate
to your boss or to different people but
Jeannie really reaches out and
communicates what
happening here she enables us to be her
ambassadors to both to her donors to
other departments the university it's a
wonderful partnership so I think if you
can communicate what you're doing as was
pointed out our donors the people on
campus people love a great story one
that they can really relate to and you
all have those stories to share so I
encourage you to do so so I'm gonna I'm
gonna be done okay Nikki this is like
how I tell my mom that I want to be off
the phone with her I want to be done now
okay
[Applause]
you